- Success.
- Define success for yourself.
- Define success.
- Success.
- Define success for yourself.
- The definition of success
- Success.
- Hello Believe Nation.
Today I want you to learn how to
define success for yourself.
And always, guys, as you
are watching this video
if you hear something
that really inspires you
please leave it in the comments below.
Put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- I think that financial
success is not success.
You know to me, when people say
for example I showed Pan's Labyrinth
and somebody said why don't
you take out the violence?
And it was very well-meaning.
Why don't you take out the violence
so you can reach a wider audience?
It's because I don't
want a wider audience.
I want the audience for the movie.
Each movie has an audience, that's it.
It's not going to get more
or less if you, with it,
if you amputate it,
if you cripple it, that's all you do.
You know, people dream
of a bigger audience
and they go, well, you
know, but is it the movie?
If in order to make more people happy,
you know Cinderella doesn't
get the prince at the end,
I don't know, it's not the same tale.
As much as I like the Disney films
of the renaissance of animation, I can't.
Every time I see The Little Mermaid
I think, but she dies in the book.
She dies at the end.
That's what made it beautiful,
that the prince was ultimately so stupid.
And I understand they are
reaching a wider audience,
but is it the tale that Hans
Christian Andersen wrote?
No way.
It's a different movie,
it's a different tale.
So if you're asking me, was
Little Mermaid successful
as a film, I say it was,
but it wasn't the tale.
It's a great, I love those films,
I really think they're
beautifully constructed,
but it's not the tale.
So Pan's Labyrinth without the violence,
is not Pan's Labyrinth.
Is, I don't know, it's a
fantasy like Harry Potter
or Narnia or any other fantasy film.
- Greatness is a different
definition to different people.
Greatness to me, is,
when I land that fakey ab
cab hill, on my skateboard,
or some.
Greatness is the song
I recorded last week.
Somebody might not find that
great, but it's great to me,
and that's all that matters,
what the I think, in my head.
As long as I like it,
that's all that matters.
Greatness to me, is finally
getting my video on MTV.
It's on there now, and I'm,
I'm happy I finally got my, on MTV.
Some people might think that's
selling out or whatever,
but I don't really give a.
That's great to me, I'm proud of myself.
I've been wanting that
since I was seven years old,
and I finally got that,
and hard work pays the off.
- [Interviewer] At the end
of our session yesterday,
you said thank you to Scott
for reviving my career,
and I don't know if that's in jest,
because I've never had
the impression that you,
you're desperate for box office,
but you choose--
- I'm jagging for it.
It's been my, it's been the thrust of my,
of my interest since day
one, when I was about 19.
Yeah, that's all I care about.
20 years of failures will do that to you.
- [Interviewer] But, on a different level,
why do you say that, and how do you feel
when you choose a role that
ends up satisfying you,
that this one clearly did?
- Well you know, for
me, with every character
that you play, you know, as long as you've
reached that, you've arrived at that place
where you believe is the right place to be
for the character,
and
if you feel that you've
done service to the,
to the director, to
yourself, to the author,
then, to me,
to me that's a success.
Box office is kind of,
you know, that's something else,
that's certainly none of my business,
you know what I mean?
Once I'm wrapped on a film, it's just,
say goodbye to the character
and then move forward.
- Everyone in this room wants to make it,
but I question how you
would recognize making it.
What is making it?
Well, what do you want to be?
Who in here wants a record deal?
Would it be nice, it'd be nice
to have a record deal, right?
We want a record deal.
Okay, well what does a
record deal look like?
What does making it look like?
Do you want to sell a million
copies, two million copies?
Well, okay, let's say,
selling two million copies
is like selling 10 million
copies, 10 years ago.
So let's say you say to yourself,
my expectation is that
I want to be an artist,
and I want to put records out,
and I want to sell millions of copies.
If that's your expectation, great.
Then, you sort of skip straight
to another questionnaire,
you know, okay, if you answered yes to,
do I want to be a pop star, do I want to
make music for as many people as possible,
now you have to
sort of change your game
to fit the expectation.
You now have to wonder about,
is your song shorter than four minutes?
Do you get to your chorus fast enough?
These are things you
have to absolutely do,
and you also have to compromise,
and you also have to
play the game, you know,
and by defining your expectations,
if you decide that you
want to be a pop star,
that's not a dirty word,
it just means, pop just means popular.
Frank Sinatra was a pop star.
Jimi Hendrix was a pop star.
Lots of people were pop stars.
What kind of pop star?
Lots of people are jazz musicians.
What kind of jazz musician?
You can be, you can define
the genre any way you want.
So if you said you want to be a pop star,
then you have to look at your songs.
There's also people here
who are a little dishonest about
what they really want to be,
and I think if you want to be famous,
if you want to make music for
as many people as possible,
just come out and say it.
Don't say, oh I want to be indie;
I'm just going to be
an independent artist,
and really secretly wish that
you wanted to be a pop star,
because, from the very
beginning, it's disingenuous.
There's nothing wrong with saying
I want to play music for
as many people as possible
without compromising the things
that I have to be as an artist,
and that's what I've done.
Sony Music doesn't come into the studio
when I'm making a record, but I also know
what's going to be a hit,
or what stands the chance
of being a hit, and what just doesn't,
and it's a level of honesty with yourself
that you have to have before
you hand your music out
to anybody else.
So that's sort of what I want
to say about expectations.
If you only recognize
success as a record deal
and a big fat Publisher's Clearing House,
oversized, Tiger Woods check,
and a dinner and then going
to the top of the roof
and screaming, I made it,
most of you will be stunning failures.
- Well if you had to give someone
who's recently graduating from our program
a piece of advice, what would you say?
- I would say to
learn and to execute
on your unique vision.
Define success for yourself;
figure out what that means to you.
Don't get taken over
by the world's definition of
success, or your family's,
or what your friends are doing,
or what anyone says, that equals success.
Once you can get clear on that vision,
then you need to create a plan
to make that come to
life, and to prioritize.
I think one of the biggest
tragedies of our time
is, I hear so many people
from every walk of life,
health coaches all over,
feeling so overwhelmed,
and overworked, and there's
so much that they can do
that they feel paralyzed.
Well, I don't know what to do first,
or what, how do I make all of this happen?
And I think that we all need
to take a few steps back
and start to get clear on
our own vision for success,
and then actually prioritize
making that come to life,
'cause then it gives you such
clarity and such freedom,
and all of that static,
and the overwhelm, starts to fall away.
- I define success two ways.
One, what I do here at the firm,
the impact that I create for my clients,
the impact that I create
for the partnership,
now the new role that I have,
the legacy that I leave.
That is one way that
I will define success.
You know, I'm not a great cricketer.
I love cricket, I wish I was
as good as Sachin Tendulkar, I'm not.
This is my life's work;
what I do here is my life's
work, it will define me,
and the second thing that will define me
is what my 11-year-old son thinks of me
when he becomes a man.
These are the two things
that define success for me,
and in that is a little bit of a conundrum
because I love what I do,
it is, as I said, my life's work,
I love my son more than I love myself,
and there's a constant tug.
There isn't enough hours in the day
to be able to do both extremely well,
and so that is my challenge.
- How do you define success for you?
What is success to you?
- I guess success is when,
is when people are listening,
and there's some measurable change in,
in consciousness, worldwide, even if it's,
even if the needle barely moves, you know.
I think that if you're communicating ideas
and telling stories, if the feedback,
if the feedback is that those,
that those seeds are
landing on fertile soil,
that's success.
I think, you know, I would say I felt that
even more with Avatar than with Titanic.
Titanic, we definitely moved
people for a couple of hours,
and they cried, and then they left,
and that was that, you know?
Avatar is a different story,
because it lingered with them,
and, you know, dare I say maybe even,
to some tiny, tiny degree,
may influence their
perspective on how we're behaving
with respect to the natural world,
and basically the destruction
that we're causing.
- Define success for yourself.
You already like that one?
Define success for yourself,
now check this out.
I'm in, south of New Orleans,
a few years ago, and I
went to a voodoo shop,
and they had this wooden
partition against the wall,
with these columns, and in these columns,
were all these vials of
these magic potions, right?
And the headings above each potion,
defining what they would
give you, were things like
fertility, health, family, legal help,
energy, forgiveness, money.
Guess which column was empty.
Money.
Let's admit it,
money is king today, it's
what makes the world go round,
it is success, the more we have,
the more successful we are, right?
Now, I would argue that
our cultural values
have even been financialized.
Financialized, humility's
not in vogue anymore,
it's too passive.
It's a get rich quick on the internet,
rich is 15 minutes of fame,
world that we live in,
and we see it every day,
but, we all want to succeed, right?
So, the question that we
got to ask ourselves is,
what success is to us,
what success is to you.
Is it more money?
That's fine, I got nothing against money.
I don't.
(audience laughter)
Maybe it's a healthy family,
maybe it's a happy marriage,
maybe it's to help others,
to be famous, to be spiritually sound,
to leave the world
a little bit better
place than you found it.
Continue to ask yourself that question.
Now, your answer may change
over time, and that's fine,
but do yourself this favor;
whatever your answer is,
don't choose anything that
will jeopardize your soul.
Prioritize who you are,
who you want to be,
and don't spend time with anything
that antagonizes your character.
Don't drink the Kook Aid, man;
it tastes sweet, but you
will get cavities tomorrow.
Alright, life is not a popularity contest.
Be brave, take the hill, but
first answer that question,
what's my hill?
So, me, how do I define success?
For me, myself.
Well for me, it's a
measurement of five things.
We got fatherhood, we
got being a good husband,
we've got my health,
mind, body, and spirit,
we got career, and we got friendships.
These are what's important
to me in my life right now.
So, I try to measure these
five things each day.
I check in with them, I like to see
whether or not I'm in
the, the debit section,
or the credit section, with each one.
Am I in the red, or am I
in the black, you follow?
For instance, sometimes,
say my career's rolling,
alright, it's way up here in the black,
but I see how my
relationship with my wife,
maybe could use a little
bit more of my attention.
I got to pick up the slack
on being a better husband,
get that one out of the red,
or say my spiritual health
could use some maintenance.
It's down here, but hey
man, my friendships,
and my social life, they're in high gear.
Right?
I got to recalibrate.
Checks and balances,
I got to go to church,
remember to say thank you
more often, something,
but I got to take the tally,
because I want to keep
all five in healthy shape,
and I know that if I
don't take care of them,
if I don't keep up maintenance on them,
one of them is going to get weak, man.
It's going to dip too deep
into the debit section,
it's going to go bankrupt,
it's going to get sick.
Die even.
So first, we have to define
success for ourselves,
and then, we have to put
in the work to maintain it.
Take that daily tally, tend our garden,
keep the things that are
important to us, in good shape.
Let's admit it, we've
all got two wolves in us;
a good one, and a bad one,
and they both want to eat.
The best I can tell, we just
got to feed that good one
a little bit more than the other one.
- One thing I believe, is
it's really important to
define your own success.
It's really important
to decide for yourself,
what success looks like, as
opposed to letting someone else
impose their definition
of success upon you.
So, whenever you begin a big project,
if you're doing something on your own,
if you're starting a business, or a blog,
or going back to school, or
even if it's an exercise
program, whatever it is,
you know, you should have your
own definition of success.
- I need to make sure
that everybody knows,
success is not money.
Alright, money drives
you up to your problems
in a limousine, right?
So, success is sometimes
being a great parent,
a great, dedicating
yourself to your faith.
There are so many people
that don't necessarily have
millions, and millions of dollars,
and they're happier than
many of us ever will be.
So, I don't want to, you know,
over push the fact of money is success,
'cause that's not the case.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know, what did
you think of this video?
What clip resonated the most with you?
What are you going to immediately apply
to your life, or to your business?
Leave it down in the comments, below.
I'm also super-curious, how do you
define success for yourself?
What does that look like for you?
Leave it in the comments, I'm
going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a
quick shout out to Blidodi,
thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and making that fun
YouTube tribute video, I really, really,
really appreciate the effort and the love.
(intense electronic music)
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you continue
to believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.